("Legendary" by Welshly Arms)
- What if I told you this was
the last Monday
morning of your life?
("And It Still" by JMKM)
- Long week.
Lot of grinding.
Life is good.
- Crazy amount of,
the denominator--
- [Gary] Nate, this is what
I'm trying to tell you and then
I layer on the fact that
I wasn't born in America.
So, first of all
it was impossible.
Then I end up in
fucking Soviet Union, right?
And then after
80 years, 60 years,
65 years of Cold War
hard-core Communism there's a
moment in time that allows me to
leave Soviet Russia,
come to America...
Jordan?
- [Jordan] Yeah.
- [Gary] How long have we
been working out together?
- [Jordan] Six months.
- [Gary] Okay. So what
are the biggest changes?
- Biggest changes
in your performance?
- Yeah. Things that will bring
value to other people
who are working out.
- Okay.
- Go deep, what
are the insights?
What's happening?
- I think number one is we
realized what was going on
mobility-wise and
leg structure wise.
So got after your hip.
- Yep.
- Sitting a lot.
If you spend a lot of time
sitting, your aren't doing soft
tissue work for your hip
you got to make sure
that's being taken care of.
Stretching your glutes
also helped a lot. Right?
- [Gary] Stretching the glutes.
- Stretching the glutes, doing--
- Stretching glutes,
mother fuckers.
- You're sitting down a lot,
you got to stretch your glutes.
Think stretching your
calves was also a big one.
Especially if you travel a
lot, if you sit down a lot,
your calves are gonna
be tight a lot of times.
So stretching your calves--
- [Gary] I'm fucked.
- will really help.
- Fuck the calves.
(Jordan laughing)
("And It Still" by JMKM)
Having a pretty reflective
morning and day.
Just things are good.
Life is good.
You know, yesterday's episode
with Nate getting blown away by
the 440 trillion to
one of becoming human.
- [Nate] Guys, it's
one in 400 trillion.
- One in 400 trillion.
- [Nate] That's crazy.
- This is what I've
been trying to say, Nate.
It is ridiculously hard to
become a human being and then
these mother fuckers complain.
You won the greatest lotto and
then, by the way, let's get real
a little more serious,
we live in America. Right?
I mean there's a bunch of
white dudes in here and
thank you for holding it down.
There's that.
People are not, people are not
quantifying their luck and they
complain about dumb shit.
- That's like winning the
lottery three times in a row.
- That's right.
- [Woman] When you first said
that, I was like you could be a
monkey or a dog or something.
- [Phil] Yeah, that's
where I was going, yeah.
- That's my thing, the whole
tree, Monday morning,
you coulda been a bus.
I believe that.
Not that I'm not confused,
I know a bus is not alive
but a tree is.
- That stat blows my mind.
- A dog is.
- That stat makes
no sense to me.
- Right 'cause it's, Nate,
literally back to your dad,
literally your dad could've
gotten up real quick and got
another glass of water and that
would changed the whole sequence
of events and you
would not exist.
- Another glass of water.
- [Phil] He's well hydrated.
(group laughter)
- Your dad is extremely hydrated
and has enormous
amounts of sperm.
(group laughter)
Even though that's
how I think about life
and my ethos, it was a good
reminder for me too, right.
I just wish people
could understand.
We're so fortunate.
Everything in life is
how you look at it.
How do I help you guys go deep
into yourself whether that is
going and seeing a psychiatrist,
a therapist, somebody
that can help you.
Whether that's to have the one
conversation that unlocks your
whole life with your mother.
How do I help you get to that
place of peace that allows you
and gives you the
power to look at life,
to look at life
the way I and the other
people that I know
are happy do?
Which is
it's good.
This bad thing happened,
now I'm gonna make it good.
This good thing
happened, I'm so thankful.
Just the whole net
of all of it is good.
It's just good.
Going to sleep.
Engaged all day with the fans.
Nothing too miraculous but a lot
of you engaged with me today so
that was good.
("And It Still" by JMKM)